el aviso es alarmante la organización
mundial de la salud anunció la
posibilidad de que la mitad de la
población europea se contagie de omicron
de aquí a marzo un micro usuaria hoy la
variante omicron representa una nueva
ola que atañe a toda la región pasando
por encima del aumento de casos de delta
a la que ya se enfrentaba en todos los
países
los hospitales ya sienten la ola por
ejemplo en parís durante la última
semana de diciembre cerca del 54% de las
admisiones y el 19% de los pacientes de
las ucis se deben a casos de omicron sin
embargo junto con las vacunas que evitan
cuadros graves de la enfermedad el
cambio de prevalencia de la variante
delta a la omicron también da lugar a la
esperanza el 14% de los hospitalizados
por la variante delta terminaba en
cuidados intensivos mientras que la
cifra es del 5% en el caso de los
contagios de omicron una variante más
contagiosa pero potencialmente menos
grave convocó la hospitalización es
mucho más corto para un micrón y mucho
más larga para el talle casi todos los
pacientes de la uci tienen una forma
grave de covite llevan ingresados varias
semanas y están en situaciones críticas
pero todos están contagiados por la
variante del ine
aunque omicron sea aparentemente menos
grave que delta su propagación puede
llevar a los hospitales al colapso dado
el masivo número de casos la tasa de
infección de la nueva variante ha
sobrepasado todas las previsiones
jones si el pico de contagios es en dos
semanas esperamos el máximo de ingresos
en las ucis durante la primera mitad de
febrero
en base al estudio de países como
sudáfrica donde el pico de omicron ya se
alcanzó los científicos esperan que el
descenso de nuevos casos pueda ser tan
rápido como ha sido su aumento pero esta
entonces los hospitales se preparan para
un duro invierno